good morning
welcome to this mid-suffic overview and
scrutiny committee meeting I'm councilor
Keith wellum and I'm chairing the
meeting today
may I first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please don't interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off similarly laptops
and tablets please
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering the meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
web webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
thank you
can I ask Alicia the lead officer for
overview of security to tell us all
who's attending today
thank you
Emily atacker is the director for assets
and Investments we have Rebecca Hewitt
who's the corporate manager for finance
commissioning and procurement and also
council is in attendance we have
councilor Whitehead who is a Cabinet
member for finance and we also have
councilor field and councilor even as
well thank you chair thank you very much
can I move to the agenda please
are there any apologies for absence of
any substitutions
none received here thank you we are all
here
it's good
um are there any Declarations of pecuni
or other registered group or
non-registerable interests by members
no there are none thank you
are there any petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme please none received you
thank you any questions from the public
none received
received any questions by counselors
don't received you thank you very much
can we then move straight on to item six
which is the draft general fund and
housing revenue account for 23.24 and
the four-year outlaw
and I'd like to invite John Whitehead
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce the report to the committee
thank you
thank you thank you chairman
um I was at the o s meeting on the 13th
of January this year that was where the
committee recommended that they wanted
to be involved earlier in the
development of the budget
so enabling a more strategic approach to
scrutinizing the budget
so here we are returning November 22 so
we're two months now earlier into the
budget process for 23 24 there were last
year with o s and I think this new
approach I'm sure will evolve over time
um but we would appreciate on s's
considered views on the assumptions
behind the 23-24 budget for both the
general fund and the HRA
so now we're looking at the period from
the 1st of April 23 to the 31st of March
24 and you know based on current
economic data then I don't need to tell
ons that this has been quite an
exceptional year when it comes to the
economic viewpoint
I mean this time last year for example
our treasury advisors were forecasting
base rates through to 2024 to remain at
0.5 percent and now they're more likely
to be 4.5 to 5 so a 9 to 10 fold error
in forecasting due to global events that
have happened between November last year
and this year
um you know since 2008 which is 14 years
ago
we've had very low base rates in Bank of
England quantitative easing and for
someone and say in their mid-30s so in
other words well into their career this
has been the norm
and so recent increases just come like a
bolt out of the blue but I think for
some of those more seasoned folks I mean
I was studying economics in the
mid-1970s these like it's been these
last few years it's been the anomaly and
more recent things like inflation at
higher base rates things like strikes
Etc overpay
seem more normal to likes of myself
um obviously we're having a separate ons
meeting for mid-suffolk here looking at
the budget because they were in
mid-sabot budgets are quite separate
um distinct outlooks
so baber has a funding gap of 2 million
for 2023 and a gap of that size we need
a 35 increase in council tax to close it
um obviously they won't be doing that
instead of looking for savings and
efficiencies and maximizing income and I
guess they'll have some quite difficult
political decisions obviously here we're
looking at a budget surplus of 2 million
so it's quite a different scenario
but given that the separate councils do
have the same Workforce I think there
are some interesting challenges ahead
um so without more Ado um Rebecca's got
a presentation a few slides to take us
through where we'll look at the various
assumptions and I think we're going to
take questions if that's okay on a sort
of Slide by slide basis rather than
leave them to the end
okay
thank you
okay so
um I'm going to take you through a few
slides they'll kind of outline what
we've already set out in the report and
give us a chance to to ask questions and
and delve into it a little bit
um so starting with the 2324 budget as
we forecast it back in February 22.
um obviously there's been quite a bit of
change since then but at that time we
were looking at a net cost of service of
9 million pounds and funding of 13.2
million giving a 4.1 million surplus
and back at that time we were we had
some assumptions around pay award so we
were assuming that the pay award for 22
23 would be two percent plus the annual
increments we assumed that inflation on
contracts would be around two percent
and we assumed that funding for 23 24
would be would be flat
and obviously events have changed since
then
and
we are seeing a lot of that in 22 23
also so
within 22 23 we are seeing inflationary
pressures of around 870
000 as per our latest latest reports
this pressures are not expected to go
away so there's obviously an ongoing
impact of some of these pressures that
we're seeing into 23 24.
first of all the pay award the national
agreed pay award was
1925 pounds per person
that's a pressure of 640 000 over the
two percent that we we had assumed
within the budget for 22.23
we've also seen Fuel and energy creases
giving a pressure of around 90 000 and
then other inflationary increases in
particular around maintenance work of
around 140 000
for 22 23 we've got the inflationary
pressure Reserve which we set aside at
the end of 21.22 500 000 will cover
um a the most of that that pressure
um but as I said these pressures are
expected to continue into 23 24 and we
can only use that Reserve once
um so the impact on 23 24 is ongoing for
these we're not expecting negative
inflation to to take all of that
pressure away
um and then we are currently budgeting
accept is around 3 million for 22.23
um well forecasting 3 million against a
budget of around 4 million
councilor FPL
thank you Mr chairman
um you say you can only use the
inflationary Reserve once
so that's just a pot of 500 000 that was
put aside for this year
so we're not we don't have a similar
reserve for next year and the years
after that's correct yeah okay
okay thank you
so what I'm going to do today is we're
going to look at all of the assumptions
that we've currently got in the 23 24
budget that we're currently building and
so these are the the key assumptions
that we want to put put forward to you
today so that you can have a look at
those challenge those ask questions give
us feedback on on those assumptions
what we're looking at here is what the
cost of service was in 2223 and what are
the pressures that that a building or
the the changes in income and what
impact that's having on 23 24.
for the pay award 22 23 as I said
1925 per FTE
um this is
councilor Equity is desperate to ask you
a question Rebecca
I'm sorry to interrupt your flow but I
think it's important for us to
understand what this document really
represents because uh to me I don't
understand
how you've arrived at the impacts
um and uh because the First Column only
talks about the budget not what's
actually happened so far this year what
you expect to happen this year so I'm
I'm really would like to understand the
rationale for these how you've arrived
at the impacts and the underlying
reasoning and what it really means
because I think then that just flows
through to the rest of the document
really
before you answer councilor e Byrne
um thank you chair because um just to
follow up if I may when you're answering
that the figures that you've given here
and they're in the paper are different
to the ones that you showed in the
um in the presentation so I was trying
to work out where that figure that you
presented in the previous PowerPoint
slide where that fitted in with this
nine nine million and 157 figure thank
you
okay so for for these these slides and
these figures what we've
done is we've we're doing the comparison
to the 22 23 budget and that's not
necessarily how we've built the final
figures so we've looked at all of the
pressures that we've seen in 22-23 and
then looked at which of those we're
expecting to continue into 23-24
so the the budget 2223 budget shows
um the budget as we projected in
February 22 but then for each section
building up those pressures that we're
seeing in 2223 that we're expecting to
continue and then any other other
changes in 2324 on top of that
does that does that help
sort off
um so
presumably you have calculated
based on what's actually happened so far
this year and what you pla you expect to
happen in the rest of year you have a
calculation for that and and
that is the base it can't be the budget
I mean you can't compare two budgets I
mean that's not
I don't see the value of that so I'm
assuming what you really mean is that
you're looking at what's actually
happened so far this year plus what you
expect to happen in the rest of the year
and then you're assessing the impact of
that and then
looking forward with that and this paper
doesn't doesn't say that
oh yes I'll say that but yes that is
that is how we have approached it so we
have looked at what has built up
this year and how that will continue
into into next year
um did you clarify Council e Burns point
and I think her question and also
Council field you have a question
right okay
yes counseling Byrne it was a about the
numbers wasn't it so
um
yes it was where the numbers that you
put up a number about the um pressures
on pay but I wanted to know where that
number was
in
that number didn't
relate to any of these figures that
we've got on those first three um rows
of that table
okay
yes
so that
um pressure there is the the 22 20 23
um per person 640 000.
um I'll have to take away where that how
that compares the 258 in that table
okay one one for me
um
just to be absolutely clear to myself
you you will shoot me at the moment
business as it is at the moment you're
not building in obviously any political
decisions to do more things or to do
less things are there any factors that
are already in forward plans that are
adjusting these figures you know we
've decided to do something substantial
that that it's occurred so so that's one
question what's the basis of the I can
see the numbers but what's the amount of
effort we're requiring if you like what
business are we running
um and the other point is just a simple
one you've got to pay award for 22.23
which you say is equivalent to eight
percent and it gives an increase of 258k
and then you take about the 23 24 is a
four percent increase and that gives me
a 513k increase
I just wanted to use that the time which
is effective or what wise why is four
percent twice as big as eight
I think thank you for for your question
so in terms of the numbers you're right
is the the business that we're currently
doing so we're not projecting changes in
the service at this point there is work
ongoing with SLT and then it will be
brought back to cabinets about further
further changes so savings and
additional pressures
um will be will be brought and that will
be a separate separate piece of work
that will follow on on from here but
this is the extension of of what we're
currently doing and what the impact is
on those
um in terms of that pay award 2223
um looking at that number now I can see
that 258
um I'll need to look into into where
that came from
apologies just to to step in I think the
the reason you've got 258
um is in in the Box against the eight
percent is that's the pressure on top of
what's already in the budget so the
budget assumed a percentage increase and
that's the amount on top of what was
assumed so I think it's an extra
accent so you can't compare it like for
like with the four percent below
yeah it might be useful to have that
clarified perhaps after the meeting
because it does it does appear to be odd
um because
I I'm not I'm not sure whether the
impact 23 24 is includes the impact that
we've already seen in 22 23 but I think
that's what we need to have clarify
cataract me on yes I think I understand
what the director for assets investment
is saying but it seems that um
effectively an extra six percent is
costing an extra 258 000 but an extra
four percent which is on top of what's
already happened would be 513 000 so you
know there is a a bit of a difference
there but I'm not sure whether it's
really quite as large as it suggested
here
if you've already increased something
once and then you increase it again
you're starting from a higher base so
that would suggest that the figure for
the four percent will be larger but is
it actually that large compared to the
previous I don't know
you'll probably you're probably right
but are we to avoid this question being
asked again when we get further into the
process it would be useful to have that
clarified I think
thank you
okay so looking through the assumptions
on the the pay so as we said we've got
the pay award for 22.23 that impact will
continue into 23 24.
for 23.24 we have discussed with the
other Suffolk authorities what they are
proposing to assume for the nationally
agreed pay award at this point we we
don't know what that will be um
pressure inflation will put on on that
discussion
um but in line with the other Suffolk
authorities we are are currently
projecting a four percent increase for
that
in addition to that we've have the
agreed pay review
um for the the councilwide review of pay
work is ongoing on this so we do not
know at this stage what that impact will
be and have included 550 000 in within
the current working budget for that at
this point until we have further detail
as that work progresses
for the pent
acion
thank you chairman
um so if I've understood this correctly
we had a the nine the nine million one
hundred and fifty seven thousand
is that the total
budget for pay
yes that's the total budget for 22.23
for for pay okay so we're expecting it
to go up by about 12 to next year
that's what the figures are saying
so
I guess my question is why would you
have a
there's something fundamentally I don't
understand about the Assumption of the
four percent and indeed the amount
that's been set aside for the pay review
um
I mean essentially what I'm looking at
here is one point
four million pounds of increase on a 9.2
million pound budget
uh thank you councilors so um there are
different they're different elements of
the pay review so the pay award which is
being assumed at four percent next year
that's set nationally and so what we've
done in terms of the assumptions is talk
to our colleagues in in Suffolk and and
um
I suppose test our assumption against
their assumptions and that four percent
is the assumed
um rate of increase for the national pay
award effectively in addition to that
mid-suffolk has undertaken to have a
review of pay across the councils along
with um with baby District Council
so that is looking at whether
um
the salary bandings are correct whether
the pay is appropriate for each each job
so it's a slightly different Focus it's
more individual and that review is
ongoing and we won't know the impact of
that until that review is further
progressed so we are making an
assumption or a provision of 550 000
pounds for the outcome of that that
we can't really do any more than that
until the the work is is further
progressed so that's a a reasonable uh
contingency figure for that pay review
process
uh thank you a couple of questions then
um obviously you've sort of talked to
other uh authorities and Suffolk to get
the four percent
um
what is the feeling nationally because I
think four percent is actually quite
conservative in terms of a pay increase
potential with inflation not likely to
drop very heavily until probably the
following year
um so I wondered whether there was
whether you've taken any advice
nationally on that and
section you've assume the cost impact of
500 000 and tell tell us that it's going
to be funded from the contingency budget
is that a reserve or is that a budget
because you've you've you've talked
about the 500 000 that you're going to
be spending from the reserve in order to
support so a little bit of clarity
really on what is the contingency budget
is it is it a separate Reserve or
thank you
yes thank you thank you for your
question
um yeah so when it comes to the pay
award and our discussions with with
Suffolk
um
we we appreciate that there will be
pressure because of inflation not
expected to come down and pressure to
increase for that to be higher we also
appreciate that central government will
be trying to keep spending down and
equally there'll be pressured the other
way
in all honesty there's not much of a
steer on which way it may go next year
at this point in time
um there was there wasn't anything clear
in the Autumn statement last week and we
haven't had any indication of of where
that would go and there is a risk that
that could be higher than four percent
and there's also a chance it could be it
could be lower but that that is what
we're going for at this stage and
obviously that's an assumption that we
can we can review and challenge
um
if
not felt to be to be the best one to
make
Council Whitehead
project
get the recommendation its
recommendation is to you know look at
the budget assumptions that are behind
this and and really it's the Assumption
column I think that's the key thing here
rather than necessarily the numbers so
in other words to
Council the scarce point about is the
four percent assumption for a pay award
next year you know is that right is that
a good assumption or should it be three
percent five percent or six percent I
think to some extent the numbers in the
right hand column are fairly irrelevant
you know big if we sort of feel or
comfortable with the assumptions then
the assumptions feed into the sausage
machine that produces you know the
ultimate numbers but I think the key
thing today is really to concentrate on
the assumptions behind the budget as
it's being put forward at the moment and
whether those are you know good figures
so for example at first the first one
which says the pay a war for 22-23 which
is 925 per person
the reality is that although it's in the
Assumption column that's now and indeed
that that has been you know agreed
nationally so although there's an impact
next year it's irrelevant in some ways
to even look at that because that is a
fact but where is the next one down four
percent is an assumption
uh so the question is
with his future predictions or
assumptions the question is do we feel
they're accurate or not and then as we
we would like to get the wisdom of ons
on that and then take carry that forward
and I say then feed these percentages
Etc into the sauce machine obviously the
third one which is a pay review there's
no point talking about assumptions there
that they're
you basically need a figure which in
this case is 550 000 because that's a
feeling as to the total sum of money
that would be needed as part of the pay
review you know to alter salaries
well I hope that clarifies
well it's sort of yeah I think it does
clarify but I think we if we're if we're
looking at assumptions we need to see
what the impact is as well so I think we
can't ignore the two right hand columns
we've got to look at look at it across
the board
and
um could I could I I think it's similar
to councilor scarf's question about
whether it's a contingency budget or a
reserve so it says that at this stage
it's proposed to assume a cost impact of
500k to be funded from the contingency
budget now if that's a reserve is it in
the budget if it's
um and
how does the 500 relate to the 550 in
the other column
foreign
I believe the 500
is potentially a typing error and that
should be 550
000.
um the the amount will be included
within the budget there isn't a reserve
to cover that when it talks about the
contingency budget I believe that is the
the vacancy management contingency that
we currently have within our budget
which
um is is equivalent to to a similar
amount
thank you um any more questions before
we move on Council field
uh just another one under one patch you
mentioned increments I wonder are they
included in the 550
um
pay review process and a view on you
know percentages and things there is
clearly a million pounds uplift in the
salary budget here which is somewhere
over 10 for
23.24 and my view would be that that is
comparable inflation it is a reasonable
sort of number to stick to so you know
you've you've created that as a four
percent Inc hike plus a
times the thing in totality does seem to
get a reasonable match to inflation so
Sansa
a valid Way Forward but I would be
grateful if I knew where the um
standard increments which are an
increase in salary where where they sit
in this set of figures
thank you for your question
um
that increment for 23.24
um will be within in that four percent I
think the four percent covers
inflationary and and increments
are you happy to press on then Rebecca
thank you oh sorry cancer Young
taking on board councilor Whitehead's
recommendation okay could you
explain the Assumption under pensions
please
yes certainly so we have recently had a
evaluation of the the council's pension
pension fund so that the pot for
mid-suffolk and that has been favorable
so we have been able to reduce our
contribution to the deficit and that we
have been making in previous years and
and this year we've there's been a
slight change to the the method for
doing that so in 2223 we had a lower
employer contribution of 23 and then a
lump sum payment towards the deficit
that the council was making and and this
year following discussion with Suffolk
County Council we're proposing to make a
26 employers contribution and remove on
based on employee salaries and then
not paying the the lump sum payment to
the deficit that we were doing
previously
um so that overall is cost the council
less
um by 353 000 as
okay to carry on
I think I could do with a 26
contribution to my adventure I'll tell
you
all right thank you uh yeah thank you
Rebecca
okay so
um that's the the pension fund as well
and then at the bottom there we've got a
vacancy management Factor so every year
in the budget we have an amount that we
assume will will be there that is due to
retirements resignations new posts and
natural turnover that the council will
never have 100 of Staff in post all the
time and therefore we have previously
had a five percent
um
effective saving in the budget or an
underspend for those vacant posts and as
the salary is increasing then that five
percent increases as well so you'll see
97 000 increase in
that thank you Council scarf
a question that we've asked I think many
times before on the vacancy management
Factor because in reality the figures
jump around 9 12 even higher percent
so the question would be as same as
usual is this a realistic vacancy
management Factor at five percent as I
suspect the figure is actually usually
higher than that and we've had had it
come to scrutiny and then come to
council and the figures of altered e and
in between
those two different meetings so is it is
it realistic at five percent
thank you thanks for that question
um
we do we do monitor the vacancy man
vacancy management Factor quite
carefully it is a difficult one to
predict because it does depend on what
individual staff members do decide to do
it also depends on the market for
recruitment at any point in time and how
difficult it might be to recruit to any
um particular role I think
um
is that five percent is a reasonable
assumption but we do you know take on
board that point that it is just an
assumption
um you know there will be fluctuations
over time depending on the the market I
suppose in in many respects and we're
cautious about
um
I suppose how we balance that because if
we assume it is a greater figure and
that will show a greater saving but
equally if we assume to lower figure
then the there won't be that and
saving and there which then may mean
that we don't have funds or we
um over over budget I suppose for that
that saving which means we don't have
those funds so it's a it's about finding
a kind of prudent
um rate that five percent seems to be
you know on balance the right kind of
assumption but we do continue to monitor
thank you I've got is this a follow-up
to that question right certainly carry
on if I can just follow up on that I
mean obviously
um we've not in mid-summit we're not in
the same situation as our partner
Council but issues like this if the
figures are an assumption which I I
still think is actually wrong
um
it would make a vast difference because
you would be uh in the case of the other
Council you would be making cutbacks and
you're making them based on assumptions
that never seem to be right the five
percent I think has has never been the
right figure as the balance overall ever
since I've been a member of the council
again
three years and we question this every
year and I just think we need to be a
little bit a little bit more cucured
with that assumption figure and it's
very difficult for us sitting here as
members to
to work through these figures we've only
got through the first page so far
probably the most significant page but
um
I don't know about other members but I'm
sitting here actually quite confused
about what what the figures are what the
assumptions are based on and and lots of
things and I think when we've got these
we're completely variable factors and
the information in front of us is not
perhaps as clear as it might be it's
very difficult for us as members to
actually make a constructive comment to
put forward into the ongoing
considerations for the budget I just
think that's the point that you know
needs to be recognized
yeah thank you Council Scott cassery but
um thank you chair I was just going to
Simply ask what has been the vacancy
management
um rate the vacancy rate in the first
six months of this year
please because I know it's I know it's
in some areas it went up to 17 last year
in particular departments but um what
has it been this year thinking
we'll have to come back to you with that
figure but I am conscious that our head
count has increased quite significant
significantly over the last 12 months as
well and so we need to factor that into
the the vacancy Factor
um debate as well because we've actually
recruited to a number of the roles that
have been vacant
um over the last 12 months but we'll
provide that figure outside of this
meeting if that's okay
or if I may what the rolling figure is
then because it was you know we will
know what the vacancy management rate
was for last Financial year and
presumably there should be somewhere
someone's recording a rolling figure on
that thank you
thank you uh Council equity and then I'm
coming to council the Whitehead
thank you chairman I heard my my uh
question is very similar to councilor e
Burns but actually I think what we ought
to be looking at is what has been the
annual vacancy amount of rate over the
term of this or this last this term and
indeed I'm sure we have figures going
further back but at least for this term
that we're sitting we ought to have the
figures and and that ought to inform
um
the assumption that we're making and
which I think is what the director was
hinting at but it'd be good to
understand what those Figures were
actually in those previous Financial
years
yes and if I could add to that if there
is a pay review and if that pay review
does actually increase salaries then
perhaps that makes us more attractive so
the vacancy rate may reduce but we I
think we need we need to make sure that
all of those things have been taken into
account uh Council Whitehead
yes I mean looking at this vacancy
management factor I think um in the in
the last year we've had we've asked for
figures we've had snapshots I mean
basically it's a snapshot in time
whenever we've been given a figure so it
might have been 12 in April and nine
percent in August I'm just looking these
figures out the air but they're probably
fairly realistic I think probably what
we need to do is almost have that
reported or the data available month by
month and sort of graph it to track it
because I think um it's on a downward
trajectory so basically when it comes to
April next year the question is where
will it be what's a realistic figure
we're saying that five percent I think
is Council scarf said it's probably a
conservative figure
um the reality is say if the pay review
goes through and as the chairman said it
makes us it makes recruitment easier I
think also we're heading into a
recession nationally and you'd probably
expect public sector recruitment to
become easier in a recession because
it's seen as more stable employment but
this gets the heart of the Crux of the
you know how difficult it is to make
budget assumptions because um you know
it's how long is a piece of string but
um you know five percent we feel is is a
prudent figure obviously we could go to
zero and that would probably put another
half million pound of cost on there
which we know is unrealistic because we
always have a vacancy but you know it's
going to be somewhere I think between I
don't know five and eight percent it's
just a question of really where are we
pitching
um you have just one other point on the
vacancy right when we've been quoted
vacancies
Statistics over the year quite often
they have been in headcount but
presumably this is five percent salary
not five percent head count
yeah thank you
um
councilor Carter uh sorry Council Castro
yeah thank you yeah no I think I can
understand why you wouldn't have a you'd
almost need a live document to have that
vacancy rate
um you know adjusting the whole time
um the um the baber
um
um employee cost
is about 700 000 less
but you still have the same um
vacancy rate in there where do we um
it is that have we got a lot of
vacancies with joint
um offices for both councils and how
does that work really with the um there
have been a lot less of a um employee
cost in favor but still having the same
vacancy rate
are we talking about people that just
work for baber
work
um exclusively for one Council or the
other we're all employed to undertake
activities for both councils and however
depending on the nature of our work that
split between
um neighbor and mid-suffolk might might
differ so it might be that you have a
caseload that has more Mid-South at work
and so potentially 70 of your work might
be mid-suffolk and therefore 70 of your
salaries may be
um
uh attributed to to mid-suffolk so there
are only very there are very few posts
that are exclusive to one Council or the
other and I suppose in terms of the
difference between
umid Suffolk and still applying that
five percent vacancy uh Factor it is a
percentage so it is looking at that
overall cost so you know if it's five
percent below a number then it's a lower
saving overall
um compared to five percent per a higher
number I suppose so there is
um the same logic applied in terms of
whether it you know whether the
percentage number is correct regardless
of how heavy the salary costs are yeah
okay
um how do we manage that effort say in
officers doing
uh yeah because obviously you're not
you're not billing for time
in in what you're doing how do we how do
we proportion that in these
budgets
do we just because I I understand you
can't
get it exactly right it'd be almost
impossible unless they're actually
recording the time sheeting all their
hours but how do we do that so why is
baby less than if that's that's how it's
working
there's an inter-service agreement
between the two councils that basically
allocate salary costs as a default it's
50 50 but I think there's some areas
like planning where there tends to be
more planning activity in with Suffolk
so I think planning is a
55 45 percent
um and for example on the uh on quite a
lot of the new projects have come out of
those million pound pots of money those
people are exclusively being employed to
work on projects for mid-suffolk and in
those cases a hundred percent so where
we've got 97 000 is impact on
mid-suffolk the equivalent figure in
Babe Ruth 83 000 so wait 97 to 83 is not
a big difference but it just shows that
on on balance there's more salary costs
in with Suffolk than there are in baby
just because they're all one of two
areas where Mississippi we're doing more
than the half yeah
thank you yeah can I can I follow that
up with a question
um you refer to the million pound pots
of money
if mid Suffolk are to make more progress
with spending those million pound pots
of money
might well it's pretty clear extra staff
could well be required in order to do
that and where would they where would
they show up in in a budget would they
would they be charged to the project
would they be within employee costs and
have we therefore assumed that we there
will be no extra staff to work on those
those pots of money
um the insta card approximately are
reserves and they are for these projects
those employees that commence save the
first 24 months their costs would go
against money already put aside it's
only if the projects were to continue
beyond that initial period that they
start to impact the base budget
so in simple terms the cost of employing
these people on short-term contracts
comes out of the jam Joe it doesn't come
out of the budget
yeah correct you
are there any more questions
um we're we I think we finished that
page if if there are a number of
questions we finish that page
um so Rebecca do you want to turn over
to the next page
electricity being one of them we have
seen in line with the national picture a
big increase in electricity cost so
we're currently forecasting 24p a
kilowatt hour compared to 14p per
kilowatt hour and previously that does
have a 255 000 pounds impact
for gas our current contract is fixed
until the end of September 23.
um there is a price cap on there as well
which is is being a benefit to the
council
a lot of the usage applies to the
Leisure centers and any increase in that
should be recovered through the contract
with the provider we do not yet know
what the price of gas will be when that
contract ends and we are seeing in the
market some reductions
um
potentially in future and we get our
guests through through a contractor
which has
um the ability to to negotiate on that
price as well so currently
um we have not put any any additional
pressure into the 23 24 budget for that
for fuel costs
um the outturn is in line with budget
for 22.23
um it's it's a a relatively small part
of the overall or budget for the council
as well
therefore based on our experience of
2223 we are not showing any additional
pressure into 23 24 at this point
for recycling and waste there's a 60 000
pounds budget for fuel and the actual
for
um actual fuel costs are lower lower
than that budget
um so even if there is a five percent
increase in 23 24 that will be no no
increase overall um because of what
we're seeing in 22-23
where we are potentially seeing some
some big inflationary increases on the
insurance premium the contract is
renewed annually in January and in the
market we're seeing some significant
increases in those insurance insurance
contracts
um therefore we have forecast to 10
increase in cost in January 23 compared
to our renewal price in January 22.
and that is a potential 50 000 pound
impact in 23 24 for that
Well Service is another area where we're
potentially seeing some increase um
on that for sound and other costs then
currently we're projecting 11 and 11
increase on that or 27
000
in refuse contract we've got a a cost
pressure potentially for for staff costs
um and then within the shared revenues
partnership we're forecasting a five
percent increase and that estimate is
based on on inflationary increases again
that is mostly staff
um although they are absorbing some of
the impact of Staff cost increases we
are expecting to see see an increase
there as well
should we pause there Council reburn has
a question I think counteracting Young
to that and Council skull thank you
thank you chair I was waiting for
someone in the committee was going to
ask but I just wondered why the shared
legal service the the 11 is is rather
much larger than the rest of the um
organization and I just
um Wanted just a bit more detail on the
Assumption of that please
okay thank you um I don't have that
detail to hand so I will take that one
away and and see what they I know there
are other costs other than Santa eating
there but I will find out what those are
thank you uh Council Backpage
thank you Joe
um I'm I'm concerned about the these
assumptions on this page given that a
large chunk of it is related to staff
costs so we've seen on the previous page
that it effectively we're saying that
salaries in uh 23 24 going to go up at
least by inflation of more than 10
percent
but all these other staff related costs
are going to increase by much less
um which for me Isn't entirely logical
and I'm also concerned that actually
with regard to the pay award in 2324 if
we have actually given staff an
inflation rate pay increase
this year why would we not give them an
inflation rate increase next year I
think we'd have a lot of problem
explaining that away so I think these
particular salary related assumptions
need a serious review
I would say
um and a much better explanation of the
the base from which they're being set
and I've got a counselor scarf
you know and it was along similar lines
to cancer riba because obviously the
shared legal costs are going up by 11
and that tells us that so other likely
costs and an uplift for salaries the
shared revenues partnership was going up
by five percent and that's based on
inflationary increases for which we now
know because the officers just told us
his pay-ulated so there is this
disparity that is really difficult to to
Fathom out
the previous two councils have spoken
about is really
right
the castle
um I wasn't surprised to see that
because there's a um there's a real
recruitment crisis going on in law
and there's um there's a supply and
demand issue where you know if you don't
put your wages up your people will move
to somewhere that will and there's
there's been um the wage increase in law
has been
higher than any anything else on here I
think and so I think that's a completely
acceptable
percentage there
it's it's different I know we've got a
recruitment crisis in lots of different
aspects of the council but the legal
professions particularly
um high at the moment
thank you
um can I ask about any
um income or saving as a result of the
solar panels at the Leisure Center you
were saying that if there is an increase
in the price of gas it doesn't matter to
our budget because it would have to be
met from the Leisure Center but there
could be a a a great decrease in the
amount of energy use at the Leisure
centers because of the solar panels
where does that figure in here
foreign
I don't have the details on that I'm
afraid of of what has been included but
I know they are will be incorporating
that into the the final budget so
um that is being looked into and we'll
all be incorporated in into that um but
I don't at this point know how much how
much that is or how that is being so are
you saying that might be somewhere other
than in supplies and services
um so thank you for the question so I
think what Rebecca is trying to say is
that we don't have that um that figure
in terms of the impact that the new
solar panels will have on reducing the
electricity cost the Leisure centers as
yet but that will be included as part of
the final budget when it's when it's
presented and in what January I think it
comes back here so we provide that
additional data at that point but it's a
fair comment array so thank you thank
you
anything else or do we know
move on a bit
thank you Rebecca
um so the next bit that we've got on the
slide is the sales fees and charges
um there is a big piece of work ongoing
about the fees and charges and and what
is reasonable for 23.24
um so just to say that this does not
include any price increases we are just
looking at the the current position and
the the forecast based on on what we
have at this present time
so for plan income we know that we are
seeing reduction in demand
um due to due to the National picture
and uncertainty within the housing
market and So based on the 2223 forecast
outturn and we are seeing a pressure of
around 130 000 there
um so we'll be building that into the
budget for 23.24
for garden and trade waste income we are
seeing a slight increase in trade waste
and then guard and waste subscriptions
as well
but we are assuming minimal growth for
the for garden waste as per the 22-23
forecast outturn so we're basing those
very much on on what we're seeing in the
current picture for 22 23 and projecting
that forward into 23-24 there'll be a 58
000 benef
324 budget based on based on our current
estimates
building control we are seeing a lot of
uncertainty in the market and some
significant change in regulations
but we feel that the 2223 budget is
still reasonable reasonable assumption
for 23 24 as well
any more questions
to that point
um Can councilor Carter
um Justin I know his proposed changes
due to uh to the B bin collections which
were due to start in 23 if I remember
from a last group report
our Visa taken account of so do you
believe we're supposed to be changing
the number of bins changing the way the
subscription service has been done
is that going somewhere making impact in
how the budget is presented how we can
if we are going to be making more bins
and changing for bins and so is there
going to be changed a cost involved and
is this cost reflected or is this going
to be done at a later date and not part
of this budget
thank you for that question so we're
still waiting for further guidance from
government in relating to the changes to
um bin Collections and there is
uncertainty
um in terms of what uh services will be
required of us and equally
um whether there will be any further
support from government to assist those
additional services so for the purpose
of this budget we haven't made any
assumptions in that regard obviously if
there is further information between now
and January February time when the
budget is set we will look to
incorporate that within within the
budget but the that hasn't been part of
our assumptions at this point in time
anyone else I've got one more question
and that is I'm looking at the Shared
legal service I'm looking at the Shared
revenues partnership
um if um if both of those services are
mainly staff
why is one going up by 11 and the other
by five percent
um I can't really speak on behalf of the
shared legal services but although I
take Council Customs point that liar
salaries perhaps of being uh you know
increased perhaps more than the average
but I do sit on the shared revenues
partnership
committee and the that's consistently
brought in its numbers below budget in
terms of costs so I think at the end of
last year we've got something like 60 or
70 000 pound actually like a dividend or
a rebate uh so um we were below budget
so by say fifty or sixty thousand
dollars a share of it so we're sort of
starting below
starting below so
um you know a five percent increase over
budget is is still a bigger jump that
then
um at five percent than it appears in
the numbers because result is starting
with a bit of a bonus coming in yeah
yeah I understand that now thank you
um can we
we just move on now we've got we've got
to
uh and we got to it
yeah we're on to interest yeah uh any
questions on interest
um
councilor even
um thank you chair I just um with
regards to the short-term borrowing
um
what I just wanted to know what those
assumptions are based on so for example
if if we were you know are there any
plans to receive any Capital receipts
that might reduce our overall
um short-term borrowing and if so is
that taken into account or or are there
any plans to change it throughout the
year
um next financial year 23 24 and
suggested more detail please on that
assumption thank you
yes certainly thank you for the question
so in terms of the short-term borrowing
um currently we're not including any new
borrowing in short term
um for for 23.24
um it will be as we look at the capital
program and that goes through through
cabinet and Council then that decision
will will be reviewed and we will have
to look at the impact of the proposed
Capital program and and build that in as
part of the the next next stage on some
kind of savings and pressures from that
varies the potential
um that we are aware that there may be
Capital receipts that we can apply
instead of instead of taking out new
borrowing and we are reviewing what that
will look like and how much that could
be so
um at this stage we do not we have not
finalized what that amount will be but
we are expecting to to potentially not
have to borrow as much as
as we would do otherwise
so so
um So currently the subject is based on
just you know business as usual with
regards to short-term borrowing
um when is it planned to be reviewed
um and
um yeah so so in terms of that figure
changing thank you
so I think for this
for this earlier time to be bringing
um budget to ons so part of the work
that's going on around developing the
budget is also looking at what our
Capital program is
um for the forthcoming years including
what capital receipts and we're
expecting so that works actually
happening currently so that that can be
presented in as part of the final budget
when it comes comes forward so there
will potentially be a change to that
impact but what we're looking at is what
those assumptions are around in interest
rates so again you're absolutely right
that work all needs to be done needs to
be done as part of the wider budget
process that we're currently
because it's just because it's such a
large figure that that nine
you know
million million you know and therefore
if so we're not going to expect to see
anything more until say January in terms
of whether what that figure might change
too
thank you uh cancer April and then
councilor Caston
thank you Mr chairman um so bear in mind
what the officers have just said
um I'm a bit surprised that the
um long-term borrowing of the rate
assumption is only at two and a half
percent
um I mean the bank of England is
basically indicating that interest rates
will go up the base rate will go up to
five percent
uh next year so it does call into
question uh both of these assumptions I
would say and
I think you know it may be as the
Director saying a bit early in the cycle
to give a more firm figure but given
that we're making assumptions I'd have
thought we ought to be learning on the
side of caution in terms of interest
rates so I'd like some commentary back
on that please
yes Ashley thank you so that long-term
borrowing assumption is for our current
long-term borrowing which has all been
fixed so the average rate on on the
long-term borrowing that we've currently
got is 2.5 percent so effectively this
assumption is that we are not taking any
further long-term borrowing that is the
the rate for for the long-term borrowing
that we have and anything else will be
will stay a short-term borrowing
I come back on that so thank you that's
a really good answer I think really it's
you ought to put that in the in the
descriptive because otherwise it's not
really clear what that means
it came to the Whitehead yeah I think in
that color if we put unchanged brackets
rate of 2.5 that's been clear right yeah
because it isn't it's basically saying
it's being changed because it's already
fixed yeah but I still think the the the
answer that was given also should be
included in the words next to it thank
you thank you
Council field you were waving have you
have you got a question I had I thought
canister Caston had one was in front oh
sorry yes you're quite right councilor
custard and then cancel the field I I
was trying to save everyone the job by
looking at the um next Monday's order
um paper but um the short-term borrowing
um are we are we bringing that down with
the income from the Investments
um
at the moment are we are we slowly
paying that off
I'm sure it's in this paper if you
probably just can't can't quite find it
yes I believe that that is the case that
that rightly in and in the in the paper
for for audit next week that is showing
that that has reduced certainly in the
first half of the year
we do tend to see perhaps that increases
towards the end of the year due to when
we receive our money um
we'll that'll be ongoing review but
um certainly any of the income that
we're getting from sifco will be
repaying that that short-term borrowing
standard amount that we pay off
that I I assume that's what
um that or have I have I got that wrong
yes the short-term borrowing isn't isn't
linked to our investments at all so
isn't it oh sorry so it's just the
the gap between what we need to borrow
based on our Capital program and our
expenditure
um compared to what we have in long-term
borrowing so that that will fluctuate
during the year based on cash flow
um
yeah that's what confused me because I
didn't think we borrowed for that but
yeah the brilliant thank you
can I can I ask a couple of questions uh
and then they may be silly questions but
I'm told there's no silly question
um do we have to make the repayments on
the long term borrowing can we not make
more repayments on the short term
borrowing so that we are still borrowing
at two and a half percent rather than
four and a half percent
um and when do we see some benefit into
this part of the budget from sales of
houses at
um noodle market and
um the range at Gateway 14.
okay so on the on the first part of the
question yes certainly we do pay down
the short-term borrowing first and
foremost a lot of that long-term
borrowing is fixed a maturity loan so we
repay it all at the end end of the term
and we will hold it throughout so right
if it's the short-term borrowing that
generally has been paid first
and then in relation to the capital
receipts that you're referring to that
really relates to the work that I
mentioned earlier in response to
councilor e Burns question so we're
currently looking at that Capital
program which includes Capital receipts
so that we can look at what
um what borrowing may be required moving
forward and also what repayment can be
made as well so that's work that's
ongoing
because that could potentially I guess
have a massive effect on this
probably a greater effect than anything
else we've talked about yes indeed and
have a significant
ly the Gateway 14 Capital receipt so yes
that's where it's currently ongoing now
and because we know what a significant
impact it could have on the council's
finances
thank you
any more questions or come to the field
yes sorry
you know I did a refund I think you
might just have got close to answering
it then the the issue I always find a
bit difficult the short-term borrowing
is just a lump and it's clearly
associated with
with Gateway 14 and and something else
I'm going to suggest our house building
program but presumably that's in the 808
budget not here so um just a question
that we convenient I think for cancers
if we tried to separate that out into
obviously big lumps but a couple of big
lumps rather than just one so one could
get a grasp of how the um the range
activities for instance a Gateway 14
might be impacting their need for
short-term borrowing in that area
thank you and I think that's relevant um
observation and certainly something
we'll try to
um present better in the in the full
budget and moving forward
so are there any more questions we
happy to move on thank you
so the the final bit for the general
fund is looking at the the funding so
the the central funding for council tax
business rates and government grants for
council tax and there has been an
amendment to the figures from what was
in the report because we have worked
through the tax base figures now in
detail so we are seeing a 3.28 growth on
the on the tax base
and that's giving you 219 000 pound
positive impact on the budget for 23.24
um for bandy for the increase to council
tax we're currently modeling a zero
increase in in the budget for 23.24
obviously that's a a discussion Point as
we as we move through the process
um as an example a two percent increase
would be 137
000 and a five pounds increase would be
two hundred thousand
we've also um got the potential impact
of the lctrs on here so the potential to
move to 100 scheme from 95 scheme and
it's currently under consultation and
just to note that although we've we have
picked up the impact on on this bit in
the slides we are expecting that in the
medium term there will be efficiencies
in delivery that will reduce reduce that
impact
um as going forward
for business rates and we don't know
what the government are going to do at
this point in time but the general
feeling with our some of our advisors
pixel is that that is likely to stay
flat for 22.23 and as it was in 22 23 23
24 so at this point we are we are
estimating and that will be the same
figure
where we perhaps will see a little bit
of a benefit is from the Suffolk wide
pool and so where all the growth will go
we're expecting with estimating a two
percent growth at this point in time
in relation to central government grants
we're still expecting a review of
funding at some point from central
government but we are not expecting that
to happen this year
we are expecting the government
announcement on the settlement of the
draft settlement for 23-24 to come to us
around the 21st of December but at this
point we are assuming that it will be be
flat so no change to the the grants the
service grant for all services delivery
Grant all the lower tier Services Grant
the good news for Mid Suffolk is that if
the new homes bonus increases with
carries on the same scheme that it was
in 22-23
um that well it has been a decent amount
of growth so
um although it's a slight reduction on
the budget for 22 23 of 399 000 and
we're still expecting to receive a
decent amount from new homes bonus
I've got a couple of people wanted to
ask questions at this stage counselor
Carter and then councilor inburn
thank you
um sorry when it comes to me an acronyms
but you never seem to stick in my head
long and when it comes into the lctrs
which sounds nice if you try saying it
together I can't it can't fathom what
actually it is stands for what it
impacts and the other thing I had with
regards to the counter tax and the
council tax increase but we recently
have um decided on the uh for the
universal credits to for I believe the
council tax is not to be taken so how's
that been impacted where we are actually
having so the lower
um rates where we're no longer getting
which very support that we need to do
this but how does it impacting our
budget what was it written about here
Q so the lctrs is the local council tax
production scheme and so that does cross
over with the point that you were making
about Universal Credit so absolutely
right there will be an impact on that
and that is the 154 000 that we're
showing there so the local council tax
reduction scheme incorporates
um the move potentially to 100 reduction
and also there's changes around
Universal Credit and how how those are
are calculated and so that's the 154 000
that
thank you sorry
and cancer even please
um thank you very much chair um just on
the new homes bonus so just to confirm
we're expecting
um about 1.3 million
this financial year
um so and secondly
what because obviously that's based on
new homes bonuses based on the the
growth over a certain amount that we're
expected to anyway and you've said it's
calculated using you know another an
acronym
um but guess could you give their
percentages please that that's based on
in terms of housing growth thank you
thank you chair
yes thank you for the question yes
you're right so I'm expecting that to be
about 1.1.3 million at this stage
um the other acronym that that's linked
in there the CTB one is a council tax
base return that we do to central
government so the figures for the new
homes bonus will come from that and they
will be the same figures that have fed
into the tax-based growth up above
um I don't have the exact figure that is
fed into the new homes bonus but I can
find that and feed that back no thank
you I think that's useful to have that
figure because it is a growth absolutely
extra one so thank you thank you and
Council April
uh just just to clarify the
1.8 million of new homes bonus that was
the budget right
the previous answer do I take it that
that's exactly the figure that we're
going to hit in 22-23
that's right that budget was set after
we'd had the the settlement figures at
the end of December
no further questions
um so there's one more line
no it's not on there it's on our page uh
yeah so we can
I can't see the screen though because
I'm not such an angular
right thank you
the general fund position with no a few
structure array position so for 22 23 we
had a budget surplus of 95 000 in the
HRA we are seeing pressures currently
mounting to around 500
000 from the pay award and also spend on
subcontractors and increase in material
and Supply costs
again we are expecting those pressures
to continue into 23 24 and for 22 23
we're currently showing a budget deficit
of around 400 000.
foreign
some of the assumptions within the rhra
so the ones around pay and pensions are
the same assumptions that we're building
into the general fund
budget
in addition for the HRA the the main the
main increases as I said are around
premises costs repairs and maintenance
costs contractors and supplies services
and equipment so we are currently
looking at around 10 percent increase on
those for 22.23
um and that's based on our what we're
currently experiencing in 2223 plus a 10
increase for 23 24.
gas and electricity we've got a higher
increase there within the HRA that we're
experiencing
um because of the difference in the in
the contracts for those so we're
currently projecting 100 inflationary
increase on that
for for water
it's based on the cost that we're
experiencing in 2022-23 again plus a 10
inflationary increase for 23 24.
that's the scarf please thank you
um well obviously the position with the
gas uh in in this table for the HOA is
significantly different to the position
for the general fund so the question
would be are we looking at uh reviewing
our suppliers because this is a huge
increase here whereas it's got very
little effect uh on the general fund
foreign
thank you for the question so I
understand that we have um some fixed
price contracts for the HRA gas and
electricity and that are due to expired
next year and so obviously we've
probably benefited from those fixed term
fixed price contracts recently and
that's why there's such a large increase
in in the cost so it's that actually
we've been protected from the the Rises
recently but obviously at the end of
those contracts we'll need to
renegotiate and enter into the best
contracts we can at that point in time
so we based um the Assumption on the
advice that we've had in terms of where
that's likely to be so it is a
significant increase but it's more
reflection on the fact that we've
probably got better rates now
because of the contracts we had in place
originally
thank you
okay so I'm sorry councilor field has
put his hand up sorry
to just continue that line of
questioning for a moment but um gas and
electricity you're saying 100 increase
and I see from
the
Theo other account that um basically
electricity was predicted to go up 100
which is still less than one's paying
personally so that seems like a fairly
low estimate but gas was up
um in your previous figures the quote
per unit whatever sort of unit that
might be was about a three or more times
increase so 100
it does seem to be
currently quite a low
guess
whether you're assuming that things will
get less problematic as
the year goes on and you know looking at
the current numbers they certainly the
price of gas has come down about halved
in the last couple of months so
a few more words about that it does look
as though it's something we could easily
get very wrong
away Council Whitehead mentioned that
forward guesses last year were
dramatically out this this could be too
you're right it's a it's been a very
volatile
um
Market particularly over the last 12
months and we've based this estimate on
on advice and we'll continue to monitor
as we progress closer to the
um the budget being fixed and we are
seeing
um
some stabilization and and hope for for
a bit more stabilization later in the
year so a lot of it will come down to
the actual date when the contract is due
to expire and I haven't got that date
right now so I don't know how far into
23 24
and the the contract is due to due to
expiring and up for Renewal but
I totally agree it is a very difficult
area to to predict
at this point in time
if you know just I was wondering our
contracts presumably are with companies
that are big enough to withstand the
loss that they must be making because we
all know bold went somewhat bankrupted
and so did an awful lot of others
so we're with someone with Deep Pockets
are we
I don't have the details of
um our contractors in this in this
regard but we do tend to work with
suppliers who do have deeper Pockets
having said that we have seen a lot of
energy companies um
Flies who have struggled in in recent
times because of those price commitments
that they made previously against the
price of gas and electricity that
they're actually having to buy and so
you
to do the the sort of prudent and
sensible thing but in these kind of
markets it can be quite difficult even
with those uh you know really reputable
suppliers to be honest
no more questions
do you want to move on Rebecca okay so
this is the
slide for for the HRA
so this looks at the income that we're
projecting for 23.24 and for the rental
income we're currently got an assumption
of five percent increase which gives a
959 000 benefit and just to point out
that this is a the Assumption on on our
existing properties that we have already
got within the HRA at this point we have
not made an assessment of what the
increase in properties might be for for
23 24 or what that would that impact
would be so that will will come further
down the road and into the into the
final budget
for garage rents we're assuming no
increase to garage rents based on on the
demand for those those garages
um it's felt that a price increase would
reduce demand and potentially
counterproductive so
um though there is no no increase
assumed there
the service charges and we've got five
percent service charge eight percent for
the heating and 11 for water just to
cover in increase in costs and that
would have a 14 000 pound positive
impact on the 23-24 budget
that's the scarf
yeah I'm interested on the garage rents
uh figure because for some time we've
we've used this uh philosophy that if we
increase the rents we'll lose interest
in the garages but and that would have a
negative impact but it could also have a
positive impact and it might actually
provide us with sites where we could
redevelop for housing
so I
I I I know it's very small potatoes in
terms of the overall figures but I think
really we should look at whether we
should actually be increasing garage
rents at least by a small amount because
otherwise
they are actually saving quite a lot of
money over a short period of number of
years by not having an increase and I I
did question whether that's right
particularly because
um we always look at the the the the
tenant's rents in terms of the houses
who often actually are the renters of
the garage not always
um and and we we generally increase the
rent as well so a question whether the
philosophy behind that is is actually
right
um because I know that we are seeing
lack of interest in garage sites but a
lack of interest in garage sites could
be seen as a benefit for in terms of
Redevelopment and providing further
social or affordable housing
thank you for that question
um we are currently looking at garage
sites across the district both in terms
of whether there are opportunities for
redevelopment as you mentioned but also
looking at how we can
um
increase the use of those sites so where
we have got void properties trying to to
re-let those so that's a piece of work
that has started quite recently in terms
of how we can look to
increase income from those assets but
also make sure they're being put to the
the best possible use I think for the
budget assumption purposes I think
because of the relatively low numbers
that we're talking about I think the
Assumption of a zero percent increase is
fair but just so you know behind the
scenes we are undertaking that piece of
work
thank you
um okay I'm sorry burn have you got a
question
um thank you chair um just on the rental
income
um and I bet I think this is probably a
question for councilor Whitehead the
assumption is five percent
um in the budget
um government's budget um
Jeremy Hunt referred to seven percent
and that's in fact quoted in all the
discussed in all the pressing of the ft
and so forth
um so is has seven percent been
considered or is that a decision is is
the decision five percent or is that
something that's still been considered
whether it might be five or seven or
something something different and
secondly really what then
um if it was to be a different
assumption because then we obviously
we're here talking about assumptions
what would seven percent mean or
something lower than five percent thank
you
thank you um
in terms of the this paper was put
together before Jerry hunt did his last
budget and my understanding is that um
he indicated seven percent was going to
be the figure going forward whereas I
think before then you know that
consultation talked about three percent
five percent or seven percent so we sort
of took the prudent middle view I mean
any percent increase will affect our
tenants but
um I think we should never lose sight
that the HRA is in a very challenging
position and you know the any increase
in rent feeds through month year after
year after year one percent we got down
there is equivalent of
uh 192
000 pounds so another two percent on the
five percent would give 384 000 a year
to the HRA
um obviously that's money out of tenants
pockets are out of
um housing benefit
um it's going to be a difficult
decision I think at full Council and you
know the original rules would have had
to CPI plus one percent which I think
was well over 11 which does seem
excessive
um so it's a really good question of
where we're going to pitch it say the
five percent is a bit historical I think
it would been doing this after the
budget rather than before the budget
we'd put seven percent
Castor casting
thank you um previously on the HRA when
we've run a surplus we've put the money
into the Strategic priorities
fund or something
um where is what's that money doing now
where is it and um
how does that how does that work when we
take a surplus out of it
so we'll put a surplus in at the end of
the year if we come in ahead of budget
then Surplus goes into that Reserve
which is basically it's a general
Reserve that even that's got a fantasy
name because it's basically the the main
reserve for the HRA the
budget deficits is it will be taken out
of there and obviously it's a limited
pot I think at the moment we're sort of
running
um around at the present rate it run out
in 10 years time whereas obviously the
HRA is is a long term you know 30 years
Beyond
um projection
yeah so I think there are tremendous
challenges within the HRA and the uh
this budget is almost like a snapshot in
time the key thing will be
working on the 30-year plan to HRA
business plan to revise all those
numbers and see where they come out
So when you say 10 years is that are you
saying it's got about 70 million
sorry um no
seven million sorry they've got my
decimal points in the wrong but
somewhere between six and seven million
are somewhere between 600 and 700 000
annual deficits back into the 10 year
yeah okay thank you
thank you Council APK
thank you chairman
um just coming back to councilor asked
questions regarding guard friends
um and I hear what the director said
about the fact that it's a relatively
small pot and
so zero increase seems fair but on on
the other side of the coin are there any
costs associated with
like maintaining these garages that you
know would impact
that we need to absorb as a council uh
and should we not be actually asking the
people renting the garages to to make up
that increase
um so as with every uh tenancy the
um conditions for your occupancy are set
by the terms of that tenancy so if the
tenancy says that we can recover costs
of repair
and we can
if the tendency doesn't say that we we
can't do it so we can't change the rules
once you've got a tenancy
um in place there will be costs um
sort of managing the the garages as with
managing any property there's always
there's always costs
um we can only recover those costs if
the if the tenancy documents allow you
to do so
can I ask a question about the tenancy
agreement does it require the garage to
be used for a vehicle or I mean one the
reason I ask that is that a garage could
be seen as quite cheap storage and you
know you could sort of lend it out to a
mate who's running your business and
that would be a cheap way of doing it so
I wonder if it's Council Scott said if
we if we did put out the the um the
garage rents we might flush out the
people who you know no longer see it as
cheap storage
I I can't respond in terms of the garage
tenances I don't know the uh the tenancy
details for our garage estate well
enough to be able to to confirm that but
certainly we could look at that outside
of this
meeting and you know it's it's
interesting to understand the the level
of interest in relation to these these
properties from
um from councilors and if garage blocks
of say 10 garages there's only three of
them that are rented out it does seem we
do seem to be putting a lot of money
into maintaining seven that aren't being
used so I think there is a piece of work
there that does need to be looked at uh
but I guess would tenants feel it's
wrong that they they have to move to a
different garage
therefore more than happy to have a
conversation outside of of this meeting
around
garages and and how we're looking at
them it they are quite complex uh in
reality they normally involve a number
of different tenances
um
and
um quite a bit of work needs to be done
in order to to change the status quo but
more than happy to have that
conversation outside of this meeting
they just seem to be a number of reasons
why it would be a good idea to increase
gel Roger and so if you if you would
look at that that would be good have we
got any further questions Council field
thank you just won I can't resist saying
presumably evidence from yesterday's was
it the day before his incident there's a
Sudbury will Point some way on garages I
think 19 got somewhat knocked over
um the the question is on premises costs
and repairs and maintenance I missed the
thought that it talks about CPI plus 10
and Quarter Two forecasts so the budgets
um two million and there's a one million
extra hit for next year which is
somewhat more than 10 percent
is there something hidden somewhere
where we're increasing the amount of
Maintenance we're doing
sort of sheltered accommodation where
maintenance is not getting down for one
to two years so that might be sensible
but it'd be interesting to know what the
basis for this
estimate is
yep certainly so the the comparison
there is between the 22-23 budget and
the 2324 budget as well as the 10
inflationary increase and the the
movement also includes the pressure that
we're seeing during 22-23 so there's
already a a difference between our
forecast for 22 23
compared to to the budget for that so
that will be part of that that one
million increase and then as well as the
the 10 so that one million is a
combination of inflation we are already
seeing in 2223 and an additional 10
forecast for 23.24
Casa casting
going back to that seven million in the
um
in the Strategic priorities fund
um are we paying interest
on that seven million
um into the HRA account
for that money
yes there is a calculation that
compensates the the HRA for that that
interest yeah you don't know what
percentage
that is based on the average interest
that the council is getting on on all of
its Investments so yeah and I don't know
the exact the exact thing yeah no but
that's yeah that's what it'll be that
you just pull in all the interest and
getting an average interest yeah the
average rate and then based on what the
HRA has and its balances
and that gets paid into the HRA that's
an income for the HRA that interests
yeah okay thank you
thank you chair
um well it's it's off the slide but it's
in the paperwork will you allow me to
ask the question right so it's not a
slide specifically I was going to ask do
we need to see the slides anymore should
we have the lights on
uh if there's no more questions or if we
need to we'll come back to them
sorry carry on Castle okay
um well on page 12 uh 5.7
um sort of identifies the work to
continuing to identify savings
efficiency and income generation
opportunities and reduce the impact of
the increasing costs within the HRA
um
now I know that the hoi is
but my question would be is it possible
for items like materials required by
housing repairs to be bought by the
general fund and recharge to the HRA at
a lower cost is that legal
hahaha
uh no I don't believe that is that would
be subsidizing the the HRA which we're
not not able to do
Okay so so is there any other Avenue
because I know this is a frequently
Asked question is there any other uh
Avenue where the general fund could
support some of the elements of the
housing revenue account costs I know the
chair mentioned one in in
me briefing because I I think if there
is anything that we could exploit
any creative way of doing that I want to
make sure that obviously we're
maximizing the opportunity because the
HRA being in in deficit and the general
fund being in a significant Surplus is
always an area which causes counselors
some dismay because you know we see the
position on the HRA and we we don't
really having just adopted the new HRA
business plan want to backtrack on the
retrofitting and all of the programs
that we've got because we're actually
running a deficit
foreign
yes we we are very restricted on what we
can do
um and we can't we can't do anything to
subsidize the HRA what we are doing is
doing a review of the recharges between
the general fund and the HRA to make
sure that they are fair and
representative of of the actual cost to
the HRA
um similarly with interest costs we know
there is some some work to make sure
that they also are fair
um and we will keep reviewing that but
we're not able to
this way to sway that unfairly it's got
to be audited it's got to be transparent
and it's got to represent the fair the
actual cost
um
a point before we come on to your
counselor uh where I said I guess you're
going to answer that which yours is a
response the the council scarf referred
to something that I'd mentioned and I'd
mentioned it last year as well and that
is that the grassed areas of planted
areas around
Council houses and in particular around
Shelton housing are seen by all
residents in villages as public open
space and yet it appears to me that the
HRA account has to pay for the The
Cutting of the grass and the grains of
trans maintenance is is that an area
that could be looked at
see whether
I mean the HRA are paying for a benefit
to all residents
is there a way of of setting that cost
I'm not expecting an answer now but
could that be looked at over the next
few weeks that was I think that was the
reference you were making Council skull
cancer at Whitehead and then I'm coming
on to council act New York
sorry yeah the point I was going to make
is that we will certainly be as creative
as we possibly can with this but we are
pretty much limited but by law but
within the scope of the law with traffic
as creative as possible and certainly
make the point the committee that
councilor headingham was a government
for housing is always all over this and
very much very protective of a baby and
is trying to maximize as much as she can
hitting funding uh you know from the
general fund where possible
thank you Council
thank you Mr chairman um I also have a
question related to point 5.7 on page
12.
but before I get to that I'm a bit
curious I mean obviously there is some
law that says we have to segregate HRA
from the Gen our general fund but
effectively it seems like an artificial
division because it's all the same pot
of activity so mid-suffolk District
Council so why are we on the one hand
generating surpluses and then on the
other hand creating
deficits that are costing us money
um and not being able to do some sort of
offsetting I mean it just seems crazy to
me you wouldn't run a business like that
I mean this is not not sensible
um and I think you know
if it is in Triangle I think we should
be lobbying government to change it it
just it's a nonsense really
um in the overall scheme of things
um so with that little rant onto my
question is that we talk about some
um uh activities uh that you know could
potentially benefit the HRA in the
transformational work and so on which
have yet to be built in to the budget as
it stands but is there an expectation
that some of this work will have a
beneficial impact on the figures for 23
24 and Beyond
um sorry yeah um I think to be honest
there's there's quite a lot of stones to
turn over you know when and I think it's
more likely if anything that um may be
disadvantageous rather than advantageous
the things we find that's my gut
reaction anyway
so we're going to increase the deficit
basically
is that what you're saying
I think there's more scope for the
deficit to increase and then decrease
but then of course that then become a
timing issue as to when when the work's
done
that's not too slippery an answer well
actually it is a silver slippery ones so
I have to say using your words but she
goes to my general point you know you're
you're creating huge deficits in one in
one hand and then the other hand can't
help it I mean it just seems a bit
I don't know I can't think of the word
for it just now but it seems to me
completely at odds with trying to run an
efficient business
um
I think the reality is we are running to
quite discreet businesses running out
general fund Council business we're
running a HRA
business which is purely and utterly
focused on our Council housing stock and
the law says quite clearly that he can't
cross subsidizer too so we we're doing
the best we can within the scope of the
statute and the limitations put on
um
I just um I'm just thinking more about
that interest on the money that in that
account that um would it be possible to
have a new deal for trust
um
in there so that a new deal is
negotiated between the HRA and the
council for the interest paid on there
because it's um a three percent the the
Baseline that's 210
000 and roughly
um at the 4.5 that we're borrowing short
term with that's 315
000 and that slows down
a bit the um the you know the the
decline of that um HRA account
um firstly is that possible or um and
the second thing is
what is wrong with the um HRA account
how do we here we've got 10 years
probably less to um to save it from
having no money and being in deficit
um do we have to cannibalize it
um I sell assets off it to keep it
afloat or is there some way of dealing
with that to make it more efficient to
um
to to rescue it in your opinion
so I think
missions within the the budget so that
we can develop that budget further
um over the next few few months and and
I think we need to be careful not to
stray into trying to fix the problems
that we're identifying in in these these
assumptions uh in this meeting and
there is a work that is ongoing and
currently and particularly with our new
housing director who joined us um last
week reviewing the HRA business plan
that was set in the summer in the
context of the economic changes that
we've seen over the last few months
particularly so we will be looking at
this in in quite some detail over the
next few months because we do need to
make sure that we do what we can to put
the HRA back onto a kind of even even
Keel so that we're in a more positive
position
um
we welcome any ideas that you may have
and we can pass those back to both
Finance colleagues and and the housing
director to to look at those in in
further detail but I think for the
purpose of today we probably do need to
focus on on the assumptions that have
been set out in this paper
um yeah no I totally agree with that um
so so the question would be um why don't
we include the interest that's coming
from that in these assumptions
um
the page there
sorry we'll look to do that outside of
meeting okay
thank you Council field and then Council
scarf
I was just going to point out one of the
issues obviously is we don't recognize
the social or economic value of
providing low-cost housing there's an
obviously a value to us and to companies
to you can employ people at large
salaries if they've got really cheap
houses and we that's not recognized
anywhere but the serious comments for
today really are you know be my view
that there are several elements of this
budget which need a very close
examination and you'll say we have new
directors on board to do that certainly
while something like gas and electricity
is is probably truly beyond our control
although we can make assumptions about
which direction that of travel that's
accommodating but there's things like
supplies equipment tools where the
increment is like 30 percent and the
premises we pay as a maintenance course
well I just pointed out the increment is
like 50
so there are a number of things that
really need a clear full examination and
it'll be wrong to make a sort of
sweeping statements here about whether
they're right or wrong but they do need
you know their organs uh
concern I was also going to point out
there are things like when some of the
challenges is this account things like
retrofitting houses with improved
insulation and windows and what
whatsoever there may be and there are
clearly government grants available in
that area and government grants you you
can never guarantee you're going to get
them but clearly we need to look at that
very thoroughly and make sure that
councilors understand
um you know just how hard we're trying
to get government money to sponsor
improvements to our housing stock which
will have environmental impact as well
as just impact on these residents so I
think there are a number of elements
here that
um
I'm not in any way saying they're being
done incompetently but do look as though
they there are some large increases and
we do need to make sure we've got the
right management effort on those
increases to ensure that there are no
more than this strictly necessary
and that maybe in some of these cases
where you know the cost of tools or
something is jammed up that you may need
to delay purchase for a year or two
until they go back to sensible levels so
you know a number of things are
difficult to follow in a meeting like
this but do need care for examination in
my view
thank you thank you
um
members are we ready to move on to
debate we've had quite a lot of
questioning and thank you very much for
the presentations and for the way that
you've answered questions it
um
we have challenged quite a lot and I'm
grateful for what you've done in
answering so
um do you want to debate do you want to
start thinking about recommendations
um
there are one or two areas here which we
might point out as areas to challenge
we what we have done in the past is
merely to say please take everything
we've said into account but perhaps this
year there are things that we want to
um pinpoint for further work
so uh
councilor yes uh thank you I was
certainly sort of challenged the zero
percent increase in garage so I think
that's been discussed quite often either
today
and I think that needs to perhaps be
reconsidered
in this chair in particular
uh cancer ipu and then counts the skull
uh thank you Joe I just wondered whether
um you're sort of asking us to have
specific
recommendations with respect to the
different assumptions or whether
actually in the round we might say Okay
given the comments that we've made
during the questioning and the responses
that we've had that the officers take to
those on board in terms of our concerns
regarding those a certain number of
these assumptions that we're not happy
with
well what we've done in the past as I
say is just to say take everything into
account but I think on this occasion
because we have spent quite a bit of
time on one or two specific or more than
one or two but some specific elements
whether we want to say take account of
question what was heard in the
questioning and the and the challenges
and the debate but in particular we
would we would suggest looking further
at the for instance the vacancy
management management factor of five
percent that's one thing that I think
has been highlighted look look again at
the possibility of
raising garage rents
and there may be other things that you
feel should be on the list I'm not
looking for a list of every single sort
of element but there may be one or two
that we particularly
feel should be looked together
Council scarf
yeah I mean coming back to the housing
revenue account and the difficulties in
terms of funding that
um I think it would be difficult to make
radical changes to the assumptions that
are in our papers in terms of how close
we are to the budget but I think one of
the things that we would like to see
is mentioned that we've got a new
director of housing for example and a
new pair of eyes brings a new outlook on
things I think there is some work there
that we would like to see done to see
whether there is any way that creative
ways of thinking could improve the
current
it might not be able to do that in terms
of this year's budget but I think in
terms of a marker for future years I
think that is something that members
right across the council have some
concern with and that we make the most
use of whatever flexibility we have to
support the housing revenue account in
whatever way that is possible I think
that's quite a big piece of work
potentially but one I think we should
ask uh cabinet to perhaps take a look at
in the longer term make if there's
something possible to improve the
figures for this this year's budget then
all well and good and if not as a longer
term piece of work it's easy to say but
difficult to put into written a written
word other than to say see if you can
fiddle the books without clearly the
books uh but but look at
um
well I don't know what how do we how do
you write it down
and look at ways of reducing the
perhaps uh simple less something like
um
looking at the opportunities the
flexibility that the housing revenue
account
um
ways of working perhaps
something like that
I think I think we know the I think we
all know what we want to say but it is
difficult to put it into words
maximizing the flexibility for the
housing revenue account
uh perhaps something like that it does
seem to me actually that the and it's
obviously not for this one but the
long-term objective ought to be that the
housing revenue account washes its face
really yeah
um and and I get I think from my point
of view if I'm going to go along with
councilor Whitehead's idea of it being
two businesses then I'd hate to be be in
charge of a loss making business of this
size and I would want him to come back
to me and tell me how he's going to get
rid of it and make it you know at least
a break even business
no
anyone else
catch the castle
um I I did um and talk about it I think
the um
the money in the Strategic
um priorities fund should become an
income for the uh RHA instead of being
accrued within the
count and be brought that that the
profit the um interest to become an
income within that account
um
if that makes sense
it seems at the moment the um the
interest from the money in the um
in there I keep having to remember the
um
from the account where the so we got
seven million yeah from previous
surpluses in that account it seems like
the interest from that stays in that
account but I think that um that should
be turned into income within the HRA
that yearly produced interest should go
in as an income
but I've I've said that and I think
that's been taken into consideration I
don't know whether it needs to be a
recommendation but it does deal with
a little bit of the um deficiencies in
the in the fund but I'm I'm quite happy
to have just said that in the meeting
and um the the portfolio holders heard
it and the um the collectors have heard
it
how's that feel I have a question for
the director actually
um the the work that we're doing in mid
Suffolk growth is that outside of the
HRA or within the HRA and to what extent
would that help the HRA if it was yeah
and it's outside of the HRA it's a
general fund function uh the OD
exception is where the HRA is benefiting
from the end product so
um for example with the uh properties
that we've developed to need a market
the HQ site we have 10 properties that
will be
owned by the HRA so they'll then benefit
from the the income return on those
properties but the other activities are
a general fund function
councilor Carter
yes I'm afraid my contributions to the
day you've been a rather hectic and I'm
in the headspace right now we are in a
meeting regards a assumptions but we
were wrong previously which we know at
the moment is some sort of we're still
working on so we know that these are
these ones are wrong but we're going to
force privacy mate and we're going to go
forward
submissions which are known unknowns and
unknown knowns that we don't know yet so
if paperwork we should basically were
waiting for the other shoe to drop we're
still for pushing through for this one
in my mind at the moment we had a
meeting yesterday where we had to be
it's ring on my ears we talked from the
CE citizens advice Bureau for concerns
but they have
we are looking at the changes of
universal credits which are supposed to
make it for
a three-month turn around but when we
lasted the Universal Credit changes we
were looking at 18 months that clients
were going without pains
we have people who are working to who
are doing free jobs but aren't eligible
for housing benefits because of the
income bracket
so we are and and we're in a recession
this is going to get worse
how secure is this
should be of a shoe drop and it's going
to get worse and hit the people and it
harder
how secure are we if people aren't able
to pay for the for the rents how much
are we going to be looking at are they
chasing for repayments and Evermore find
a more
costs that way are we looking for are we
going to be seeing okay yes we're going
to make a loss next year but we're gonna
have to deal with it later are we
thinking of
people may be out without benefits about
18 months we may have to get
swoop into actually cover the cost like
we did last time and are we going to be
having the inflation that way are we
thinking about in this budget I don't
see it reflected there and also we've
got employment where we must be a secure
employer
yet when we're looking at
are we who are what bracket are we
employing because if it's be what age
group where are you looking at some ill
for
grandparents for having to leave work to
look after children
which are saying reason why we haven't
lost in volunteers
it's just going to be affecting us as a
business who are we employing how secure
is it we don't know whether or not we're
going to be able to afford to be able to
work for us if they're going to be in
their brackets to it so
this budget is
how secure we're it's looks great and
paper is good for you but how genuinely
secure is it where next year we have no
idea how many other she was going to
grow up
and what's the point looking at if we
don't know yet
um well uh councilor Carter we look
we're looking at comments to be made in
the in the recommendation and
I mean by all means we could express our
concern about the unknown uh well
expressed concern about the unknown but
I think everybody knows that there's an
unknown so I'm not sure that's worth
putting into a recommendation to
um to to Cabinet to the two offices or
or the portfolio holder
um
I've got cancer right for you and then
and then councilor
cast of the council feel did you want to
make a comment at some point but not now
I'll come to you in a bit
well
well let's let's see let's see if it
comes up in debate if it's a burning
issue that you feel we need to take into
account then I'll come to you
okay uh Council Repco
thank you Mr chairman I think I think
um if I if I was going to make a
recommendation it would be that I think
with regard to the pay award and
um
effectively anything that's really got a
huge influence in terms of task of
course we ought to be looking at
something that's in line with the
anticipated inflation rate for for next
year which is in the order of six
percent
um because I think that would be the
more prudent step to take rather than
assuming we'll do better than that and
that I guess would be one of my
recommendations uh in going in terms of
how we look at this
assumptions going forward
uh councilor Caston
yeah I was just going to say I think
we've got we've got a couple of
recommendations there
um I'm quite happy for what's been said
in this meeting to be taken on board
and um
maybe leave it at that because um this
is a really difficult thing to do and
thank you so much for everything you've
done in this meeting it's been a lot
more intense than maybe I you know I
thought it was going to be but you know
it is is budget and budget always seems
to be like that and um thank you very
much for um you know everything you've
done particularly Rebecca who I think
some you know had to just been brilliant
with answers and just had to um sort of
um defend quite a lot in there but um
it's um
difficult piece of work to do because
you're working with things that you just
don't know and if if you say one thing
the counselors will question you on the
other it's you know it's what we what we
do we're here to just try and pull
things to Pieces the best we can and um
yeah and but um no it's um but thank you
very much but yeah that was I didn't
know if you wanted a proposal well I was
I was going to read out the notes that
I've got here at some point yeah yeah
um Council have you got somebody to say
that might make a difference to this
I'd hope so my thought just is that
there is considerable concern about the
HRA budget
Council Whitehead pointed that out that
what recognizes the administration where
we working on that but the committee
should recognize there is a problem and
that it would advise that various
elements of that for instance premises
and repairs cost
costs supplies tools and maintenance
need a very careful examination and
detailed justification of them before we
push ahead with this budget
it's a vital account it provides an
important function and we need to be
absolutely sure that it's it's it's been
managed as well as it possibly can be
bearing in mind there have been a lot of
staff changes so and recommendation
that's just comments I think you need to
recognize you need to recommend that
it's looked out very carefully and that
the results are made visible to the
committee
that would be my view there are some
costs and there is always a suspicion
that we're
suffering big costs because we're trying
to expand our housing stock and that's
like investing for a future business it
shouldn't be carried by the current
business and we have
tenants who are not the most wealthy
people in the world who are at risk of
carrying considerable costs that they
shouldn't be carrying so he must make
sure the two elements of it is growth or
in fact it's three elements is growth
it's moved to be climate
to change compatible whatever we call it
um
and it's it's um it's existing running
course it should be clearly seen clearly
analyzed and we should have a a view
that we know what's going on because
clearly the
illustration member here the the pool
for Idaho was concerned about the
overspend in this area
needs examining carefully sorry that's a
very long way of saying that simple
thing
thank you Council field counselor acryl
thank you Mr chairman
um I'd like to start by
um
you know endorsing councilor Customs
comments regarding the effort that the
officers and the portfolio holder put
into
the process so far and and to thank them
for the uh the clarification of the
various points that have been raised
during the course of of the meeting
um that said I am
uncomfortable with the way in which we
present budgets in this Council
um it seems to me that we've we spend a
lot of time comparing a new budget with
a no budget and I frankly don't see much
value in that
um if if you set a budget and I've been
doing this all my professional life you
set a budget then you see how you
perform against that budget and I note
that
um currently uh the cabinet are not
going to get and the out turn for
Quarter Two until next month which is
almost a full quarter after the quarter
has ended well that doesn't have never
happened in any business I've ever been
involved in you usually get that
information within four or six weeks of
the quarter end so in a sense I feel
that we're being asked to look at a new
plan without much
information about how we performed
against the last plan
and I I do think that we need to address
this issue because if I'm a someone
looking in at this meeting on YouTube
I'd be going what are they doing what
has actually happened
they have a budget for 2020 22 23. how
did that work out and what's the
forecast for the end of the year and
then how does that inform the new budget
um and and it seems to me that this
community is being asked and and indeed
Council has been asked in the past to
make such commentary uh without that
information being readily available I I
don't think that's quite right and I
think if I had one particular request is
that that whole process needs to review
foreign
yeah I understand that and and I think
that really is a matter for audit isn't
it too
rather than for
rather than for here to but
um
so do we want a recommendation that they
look
and look at more timely
uh
presentation of quarterly well I think
there are two things Mr chairman one is
the getting the actual quarterly
information in a more timely fashion and
the other one is really actually also
being able to look at what what's
actually happened versus what we said
would happen and and what are if you
like the rest of the year outcome is
looking like and therefore how that
informs the new budget
foreign
right the things I've got written down
here are
that we welcome this earlier opportunity
to consider the job budget assumptions
and Bank offices for their presentation
and clarification
we request coverlet and officers to take
account of comments made during
the meeting
we asked them to look again at
opportunities to reduce recharges from
HRA to general fund
and look again at the vacancy management
factor of five percent
consider further opportunities to
increase
consider further the opportunities
to increase garage rents
to suggest a more prudent assumption in
respect of the pay award for 2324 could
be six percent
um
we recognize that the HRA budget is
finally balanced and recommend that that
costs
stop there
the costs of the various the various
elements are
looked at very carefully
um
something like that
the first one the first one
we welcome this earlier opportunity to
consider the job budget assumptions and
thank offices for presentation for their
presentation and clarification
that was what yeah that was what I said
that was the first yeah sorry yeah
that's okay
um it's
it's what we can say about we recognize
that the HRA budget is finally balanced
and as councilor field pointed out we
recommend that
um the assumptions made against
in particular I think it was
um
costs of
cost of repair maintenance supplies and
equipment
I mean it's mainly it's the repairs and
maintenance because that's where
that's where the bulk of the money is
the assumptions made against the costs
of repair and maintenance be looked at
more carefully
more carefully um
in more detail
rather than more carefully
and then the far the final one was to
try to put into the written word what uh
counteractory young said about
um we would ask for a more timely
quarterly information on the general
fund in HRA
income and expenditure but that is
something which I think probably does
audit look at
these quarterly reports
from
general fund and HRA
so they just go to cabinet
so we just asked that cabinet are
provided with
well the thing is that if it's provided
to Kevin in a timely fashion then when
we come to have this kind of meeting
that information is also available to
the committee it's also part of the
budget
a process
of understanding how we're we're
performing against
the current Year's budget
and how that then influences the budget
we're setting for the next financial
year
so what I've written down now is a more
timely quarterly information on the
general fund in HRA income and
expenditure
and for this to be used to develop the
general fund and HRA budgets and made
available to this committee
shallow shall I read them all
again
I would rather I know there's one or two
heads being shaken but I would rather
read them all again and then having read
them all if you're happy with them will
then will then vote and then you can
you can trust me trust the officers uh
and I to to put them into some sort of
sensible order if you're happy with that
we'll go ahead on that basis so
we welcome this earlier opportunity to
consider the draft budget assumptions
and thank officers for their
presentation and clarification
we request that cabinet and officers
take account of the comments made during
the meeting
we ask that they look at opportunities
to reduce recharges from HRA to general
fund
and to look further at the management
vacancy management factor of five
percent
to consider further the opportunities to
increase garage rents
we suggest a more prudent assumption in
respect of the pay award 2324 could be
six percent
um
we recognize that the HRA budget is
finally balanced and recommend that
the cost assumptions in respect of
repairs and maintenance be looked at in
more detail
and we ask for a more timely quarterly
information on General funds and HRA
income and expenditure to be provided
and this information to be used to
develop the budgets and made available
to this committee
which is that all can I can I ask
officers if is that okay if we
if we write that all out
we'll spend a little while before the
before we depart so on the basis of what
I've read out can we go to do we want to
go to an electronic vote
um so yes so are you yeah we're doing it
we've got a proposal here at Council
April young and Council cast and
secondly thank you
right so thank you chair members that
vote is now in progress
cheer do you want me to take your vote
verbally um
I think I'm there now
last
thank you chairs that is six votes for
us that is unanimous thank you very much
and yeah that concludes
the business
of the meeting and the time is 11 50. so
thank you very much indeed and thank you
officers thank you
um Council Whitehead
thank you very much
the next meeting will be on the 19th of
December